[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as us chess champs calm
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome back to the
2019 summer chess classic my name is
Caleb Envy and I'm joined here with the
wonderful GM Jessie cry and today is
actually round three of the event it's
been an exciting first two days and
round 3 shaping up to be just as
exciting I think we can and take a look
at the standings currently for a group a
it looks like we got to wait I actually
this is I believe the only section where
we have a tie up at the top David Hal
won his round one game against Sam
Shanklin and that put him at +1 the
score 1-1 and a half Geoffrey Zhang also
won his round 2 game I believe putting
him also at one and a half following
them are going Jones and Darius wits
both with two draws in the event liam
Lee is rounding out the group with Sam
Shanklin both at 1/2 point and in the B
group we have one man ahead of the rest
which is Surya Ganguly he's actually 2
and O 2 so far in this event which is an
incredible scores start out with
following him our San 7 Daniel Friedman
Grigory Oberon and rounding out the
group is Havana's kuboos Ian and Igor
Kovalenko in the C group we also have a
seat clear winner
thus far in Brandon Jacobson the young
random Jacobson is actually at one and a
half out of two with one win and one
draw and then there are a myriad of
players I think following him at one
point we can take a look at the format
of this event we have three six player
double round robins so that means there
are three different groups each with six
players and everybody plays everybody
else two times around
the time control for the event is 90
minutes for the first 40 moves in 30
minutes
added on after that sudden death with a
30 second increment for move one there's
also a 30 move draw rule in effect so
that means the players will not be
drawing any games before move 30 except
by repetition we can take a look at the
schedule for this event it's a brutal
schedule with 5 5 days of games in a row
one game a day with one rest day and
then 5 more games directly after that so
not too much rest for the players you
can join us here actually for every one
of those rounds starting at 3:30
two and a half hours after the start of
the players scams and you can join us on
YouTube where we'll be keeping an eye on
the chat you guys have any questions any
questions for the players once we get
them in the interviews we'd love to hear
it love to pass those on and join us on
us chess champs calm if you want to
follow the games for yourself and you
can join us on Twitter as well using the
hashtag summer chess classic with that
in mind so let's just jump right into
the action here let's see that the
pairings for group a liam lee is
squaring a god squaring off against
tournament co-leader David Howell
Darius Ruth's is facing going Jones and
Sam Shanklin the number one seed is
playing Jeffrey Zhang in our key matchup
Jeffrey also leading the tournament with
David Howell and so that's one to keep
an eye on and it's quite the interesting
position I think it's reached some
simplifications now but definitely a lot
going on here Jessie why don't we take a
look at it simplifications but not
simple and I think you know what Sam has
definitely got to have on his mind as
his round one loss to Howell or is also
a rook against two minors and in that
position black had two pawns and that
position I guess was better than this
but this is still very frightening and I
would say black is really the only one
who can win this position black just
played b4
and let's take a look at how we got here
I was up there watching the game and Sam
clearly chose this opening to surprise
his opponent and you know it's just a
feature of modern chess that nowadays
everybody's playing different openings
and I think Magnus is the one who really
started this tradition where back in the
day people believed in their openings
they thought like this is the right way
to play and Sam is playing a bunch of
different stuff and I would say he won
the opening battle in just in the sense
that Jeffrey thought forever here and he
got some time on the clock and Sam's
next several moves were all played
basically instantly you can see an ID -
it's a kind of prep a move you probably
wouldn't just instantly play on the
board right this is something he's
thought about so we got this position
and I thought that white was better
maybe the king is a little bit better
our pieces are more developed right so
this all happens and Bishop a5 it's
funny you start with a position you feel
is just a little positionally better and
then within a couple moves we're gonna
get into complete mayhem so night at
four he could have done other things
obviously Knight a six and he tries for
Bishop a5 and Geoffrey plays check to
the misérable King and then it says okay
you can take my pawn
but if you do the drama of this all is
you're going to eventually have to take
on b4 and then when you take on before
you're gonna have to worry about the
bishop coming to a6 and checking the
King so this is what got insane and
this all happened and there should be
five is forced otherwise Bishop a six is
coming Wow
and here black could have had a choice
between g5 and the movie played in the
game a six that forces this move check
to the miserable King and this is
getting close to the game and here Sam
makes a very committal decision which I
guess I'm gonna call incorrect I don't
know if he's got a better move than this
but it seems like if this is his best
move
it's not what he really wanted from the
game namely h3 Knight takes c3 and we're
gonna get the situation we get in the
game so snip snip snip all this goes
down and I think we'd rather be black
for no no other reason is very hard for
black to lose this position and of
course the Knights first of all if you
trade off all the pawns the Knights are
the two pieces that can't mate you so
that's a look but the next thing is the
rook is so powerful once it gets behind
the position and particularly if it
opens the position up so it might be
able to invade here's that's what you're
saying rake it and on the second rank
somewhere right and it's very difficult
to see how white wants to claim that
that he has any weaknesses to play
against right like we can tickle b6 but
it's gonna be a real chore to try to win
that guy so really I would say very
interesting position either a little bit
better or clearly better for black yeah
I'll tell you I'll say actually from a
practical perspective I'm gonna call it
clearly better clearly better just just
on a practical level because black is
going to be able to play on and play on
and as long as no counterplay happens
against b6 the the party's just gonna
continue I might have to disagree with
you on that one okay what if white just
puts like a knight on d3 that just
defends the b2 squared and the night on
e3 and then how do you do anything with
black kind of ever eventually we're
gonna bring the king in and get past
pawn on the Kings side all right do that
I guess it's right land but so I'm gonna
guess that we're gonna be here for the
next several hours we're gonna be there
let's see what happened actually some
stuff did happen yes so they're playing
quite quickly here so Knight did go to
d3 d4 Knight C to b3 you could have
taken on a3 but here's a nice trick rook
takes 83 kind of highlights the inherent
weaknesses of the Knights that was a
very nice move and yeah unable to stop
that passed pawn would be b3 if white
were to recaptured this this looks that
was beautiful and this looks very
difficult for one very difficult you
know we had a great interview with
Jeffry that you guys can pull up and
watch at any point yesterday and we were
talking about him reaching 2700 and he
said is mostly psychological kind of I
thought that was interesting in a game
like this you know you really have to
believe in yourself to win this thing
you know clearly you're better but Sam's
gonna put up a lot of resistance kind of
like what you were saying caleb is the
the pawn on b2 is at least invulnerable
in the sense that the knight on d3 can
sit there so you know black is gonna
obviously try to improve the King and
the pawns and you know it's going to
happen but you know it's gonna be a long
struggle yeah interesting that Sam keeps
finding himself and with these two two
knights that seem to be a little bit
awkward against against the rook you've
got to be traumatized from when he did
it the last time actually let's just
revisit how this happened you know did
he miss yes this is it I guess
tactical exchanges here what else could
he
try maybe instead of h3 he's got a lot
of different moves he can play 94 he can
play eith yeah 94 comes to mind
mm-hmm you know maybe a three it seems
like there's gonna be more than one
thing so uh 94 it can Kim black just
play Ricky eight and take this this epon
probably something like that but let me
just put it just positionally like our
King is better so we should be able to
find something even if we give up a pawn
but giving up the way it happened that
didn't seem right to me
so yeah I don't know there I think
there's more than one thing that with it
white can try here for sure
but H you know and maybe we've already
messed up if we have to do h3 cuz this
looks this list this is just beautiful
for black and let's show the trick again
cuz I thought that was real sweet that
was quite a nice e to b3 Maggie for rook
a three and Knights are terrible when it
comes to pass pawns that's one of the
reasons why I think when you when you
imagine the rook versus the two pieces
this is the worst imaginable do pieces
for the for having the two pieces yeah
Wow
so yeah interesting stuff and a lot of
kind of a tactical flurry there just to
take almost all the pieces off the board
from a pretty pretty dense position as
far as number of pieces are concerned so
yeah we see rook do one now it's gonna
be a lot easier to for black to just go
back and forth and massage them because
Sam is gonna think have to think on
every move and you know really all
Jeffrey needs to do is come up with a
plan of kind of advancing the pond
bringing the king in all right well a
lot of interesting games today why don't
we take a look at what's going on in
Group B sure I'm gonna take a look at
the pairings and see what we've got
so Gregorio Oberon is paired against
Daniel Freedman Igor Kovalenko is paired
against in collusion and then we have
our tournament a leader in the B group
Surya Ganguly and our key matchup
against Sam Sabean who has drawn his
first two rounds I think he's the number
one seed and the B group so I'll
definitely be looking to make some
progress here and chip away maybe at
this lead
yeah well he's lucky to draw if he gets
this one alive definite grief versus
heavy on in this position and a really
nice game from Ganguly and actually it's
the opening is something we were talking
about yesterday so we got this position
and castles are not just to refresh her
memory here what happened yesterday with
I believe Howell against was how who was
he playing in that game he was playing
hold on how agonizing he drew his game
right against Weir's
that's right so he was playing spirits
and you know in this position played
Knight b6 and then how will played the
setup with d3 and Knight d2 and trying
to get like a much better Hedgehog than
you normally get with reverse colors and
it's really the same thing that happens
today just that seve um plays is Knight
to f6 and this placement on f6 with
reverse colors is more popular these
days and so you'd have to say to
yourself okay this has got to be fine
but as I said with that game the Howell
game I think it's much easier for a
white to play yeah all the pieces are
finding themselves and if we need to or
want to we can always play for e3 and
I blocked the the D file this D four is
a thought to and that's actually gonna
happen
Wow so Bishop f5 27 d4 and this is
already I think unpleasant so if he for
which is what happens we're gonna slam
it in and if de them we're just opening
everything on the long diagonal you know
weight just puts his pieces on squares
and then you know it all kind of breaks
loose at the right moment and here's a
nice shot that it's gonna lead us to our
current configuration 96 Wow takes takes
95 and white probably could have played
rook after he won first he just snipped
and let's say that white has a pleasant
advantage here we have the better minor
piece and the plan of course is
problematic and in particular after
knight c6 what White's gonna try to say
I think is that not only this is weak
but the king side is weak as well yeah
just the the bishop sting is much
stronger than the night here no word
really for that night to hang out
besides maybe that that ee v square and
that doesn't seem doesn't seem like a
permanent strong and one way to talk
about the difficulty for black I think
is to say that in order to prevent
getting mated you would like to trade
Queens mm-hmm but if you trade Queens
then you're headed into an isolated pawn
situation that you really don't want you
don't want to trade off the Queen's and
have the rooks just simply double and
you can tell right it's not going to be
possible to stop the rooks from doubling
just looking at it here simple chess he
says goodbye to the Queen's and says I'm
ready to suffer I'm gonna assume the
position here
right and it's close to lost the
weakness of the deep pond combined with
what we call the fissure endgame which
is the rook and Bishop versus the rook
and Knight and a very simple way to
understand the fissure endgame is just
to count the squares of the bishop
controls and actually look at all those
blue dots it's rare that get all those
blue dots so I'm getting four five six
seven which is technically more than the
Knights presently going to get you'll
see those the game progresses the bishop
will get more and more squares the
knight of course a maximum of eight
squares and the point is is that when
you have a bishop versus a knight the
problem for the bishop is it can only
touch one color but when you have the
fisher endgame with the rook and Bishop
you're gonna be able to touch in both
colors and that's why they can really
complement each other especially in an
endgame like this so let's look
g4s six h4 it's very easy to play white
but the pawns and the light squares and
we're gonna be thinking about g5
whenever we're good and ready to do it
there's no counter play for black and
black you know he can do so many
different things but there's nothing
that is pleasant alright there's nothing
that's Pleasant and the idea clearly
what black is playing with f6 is to
limit the scope of the bishop on b2 but
clearly it's gonna get popped open at
some point with g v g5 notes that
there's h6 threats as well h6 threats
and I'm sure black is considering h6
right now one of the many ways they can
choose to suffer he actually played
ninety five and the good tactical point
of that at least is that if g5 pawn
takes King takes there's Knight f3 so at
least the immediate g5 isn't possible
but you know there's a variety of ways
now for white to improve
position yeah it looks very very
difficult for him what uh what do you
think happened to in this game because
this just seems this seems too
unpleasant to kind of just fall into
naturally right oh no I think it's very
very possible to fall into it naturally
when you get this position in the
opening yeah and White has not committed
to Knight c3 like we saw in the howl
game and then it's just difficult for
black to play because White has the
extra pawn in the center and it's harder
for him to find a plan and so he starts
flailing a little bit you know I was up
there watching and he just made that up
at the board and he's still fine he's
still fine but it's like they should be
six maybe a minor inaccuracy it's not
the end of the world very simple for
white to play obviously and the point in
these assists Sicilian dragons a weird
thing right because in general in the
Sicilian you're advantages that you have
more center pawns but in the dragon this
point is kind of hanging back right and
so we don't know Oh first of all it's
not let's put it this way it's not in
use right now but it can always come
into use later right right like later in
this game we're gonna see III and it's
not a it's not over I mean I don't yeah
this is an Ganguly just playing simple
and good chess yeah it's a fancy one
things to you know actually I'll say
this is I'm pretty sure if I was white
here I would have played g5 just to make
sure I got that break in now I'm
assuming that in this position there is
a way for white to organize g5 maybe
even the brute allistic rook g1 but the
in my face is a practical problem at
least that white has to solve right now
sure let's go look at groups eat
absolutely let's see our pairings for
Group C we have Gordievsky plans Trula
and Alshon morontia body has drawn his
game against toronto Cobian and our key
matchup of the day is archers Naik Suns
against Group C leader Brandon Jacobson
who is plus one so far and let's take a
look at those players there and let's
see what's going on in their game
Brandon is finally suffering finally
suffering which is proof that he's human
at least alright right
the kid is obviously a genius but he
made some funny moves here and I think
maybe more importantly he got himself in
severe time pressures so I'm seeing one
minute left for 11 moves and I think his
mistakes earlier to war due to time
pressure I liked his opening a lot we
had this Bishop b5 Sicilian it seems
that Brandon's been doing quite well in
his openings tournament absolutely I
mean advantages with weapons and getting
the usually getting the time advantage
and here too he he honestly had the time
advantage and these moves he was playing
them instantly
all this was fun I loved this setup
actually to shave me then win this game
because this setup I thought was very
clever now normally in the hedgehog
you'd imagine having a knight here and a
pawn here right but the advantage
there's two advantages with this night
on on g6 it looks a little funny but the
one advantage is obviously it's looking
at these dark squares but also you have
the option of playing a later f5 and
yeah I think it's very spicy and nice
for black and you know if you imagine
that five followed by a later Knight age
for hip so rook F t1 he calmly defends I
was thinking maybe he was gonna try to
sack the pawn but there's no rush f3
Bishop f6
Queen d2 Queen Issa I love the ways
played it so far and the difficulty for
white is how do I use my space advantage
to really crimp the pieces if I play a
four then it's a pawn sack with Bishop
c3 and Bishop b4 hmm so that's the kind
of strategic issue rook a c1 rook b8
vision f1 Bishop b5 this part of
Brandon's play I thought was just really
nice you know it looks like a timing off
Sicilian position we're looking at this
f4 square white doesn't want to play f4
maybe he should think about Sachi the
boy anyway you know he plays 92 calmly
Bishop d7 beautiful and now f4 which I
feel is interesting you know do you
think about it if you're white of course
you want to play f4 you want to take
away that square but it's highly
controversial because can take it back
weakened the e4 square and strengthened
the bishop on b7 right so Knight c3 and
it was in this position that Brandon
thought forever and I didn't like his
move I felt like the natural Hedgehog
move here would have been to play f5
giving it really highlighting know the
LightSquared bishop light square bishop
and depending on what white does you
know we're also highlighting the f4
square absolutely
if e5 I think you're just suffering for
a long time I mean he's got I think he's
a freaking year no matter what he does
so I thought maybe we'll get a chance to
talk to Brandon later about white and
play f5 because his move is way more
complicated than a 5 maybe after after
f5 and E 5 was Brenda maybe worried
about like Knight b5 coming and then
neck to D late to d6 he was definitely
worried about something
there's no
question five looks real controversial
let's say night age four hopefully they
say night be 500 juice yeah there might
be five I was hoping you didn't make it
threaten I'll just go ahead and play a
I'll play 96 yeah
so here white can black can take or he
can just move the bishop somewhere one
of those things and then we're gonna
play King h8 and roof g8 yeah g7 but I
don't know
it's definitely you're committing to a
lot they're right with letting this
piece stay on d6 that d7 Ponzo is gonna
be kind of backwards okay I'll take it
alright I'll take with my queen
and maybe I can play Queen and I wanted
to play Queen c7 but maybe it's it's not
doing doing enough for me but yeah I
said I think what you are at least right
about is he feared something yeah
there's something done this position and
then after he five honestly Black has a
lot of different moves you know you
don't and 95-96 it's not it's not really
gonna get you for example another move
you could even think about is Queen like
Queen h4 is a little weird but yeah you
can think about Queen h4 sure yeah maybe
like White has other ideas like Queen f2
and and something like c5 could come
it's so hard to do anything over there
but okay but ya know I think you are
right that he feared something like this
yeah for sure but so yeah he played d5
instead which looks very very combative
right it's weird you know it's like
White's whole whole setup is so you
don't play d5 and then he doesn't
anyways well look how complicated is
yeah and then he plays work fe8 my
goodness and you know I don't he's
clearly he clearly had some very okay
the deep thoughts have to be when this
opens up the f4 square is going to be
weak and the diagonals are gonna be weak
and white I'm sure had many different
moves here and maybe the biggest problem
here is this Brandon just didn't have
enough time here clearly we got to say
that at the very least white doesn't
have anything to worry about anymore
right I agree because that night needs
to fix itself
and then we do well this business oh and
let's get to the current game position
so a couple moves have happened since
then let's just Bishop c5 now let's
think about this how bad is it it's
definitely worse is it clearly worse
you'd have to think it's fairly worse
with the no entrance on d2 right and
there's a bishop on b8 has some grief of
its own black just played back the worst
bishop and the worst number of pawns I
think having less pawns is never great
it's still it's still a lot of things
could still happen but I imagine say
Bishop c3 and the other problem of
course is Brandon's got 36 seconds left
the kids nowadays they like it when they
have less time anyway but but you know
it's not really what you want yeah we
see Brandon there he doesn't look like
he's 15 does he know he looks a bit
older maybe yeah but he dresses well
so yeah with that in mind why don't we
take a quick look at the prize funds for
these events because they are actually
quite large for the first time we
actually have a $40,000 prize fund just
for the a group and that's actually
about double what it used to be at these
these classics first place walking away
with $12,000 second place getting 9,000
and in the B group quite a substantial
fun there as well six thousand for first
place and a total prize fund of $21,000
and over in the C group four thousand
for first place and fourteen thousand
dollars total so it's quite a bit of
money at stake here for these players as
well as you know so crucial rating
points as they try to climb their way up
that a GM reading ladder which can be so
tough with that in minds I guess we can
go wherever we want now that let's let's
go to the a group
with Sam's game and then we're gonna
look at the other two games so all three
of them are really interesting we're
gonna see a long term massage here
that's predicted and the you know the
thing I said was blacks gonna have to
find a plan that's the most important
thing and I like what he's done is the
first step is bring your king in make
sure that you're not going to lose the
b6 part of some dirty Knight trick and
then at our leisure right we'll bring in
we'll start some kind of advance on the
Kings side if you imagine let's um let's
do a thought experiment let's say we
vacuumed up let me get rid of the rid of
it I want it clean let me get rid of all
this stuff let's say we vacuumed up this
these four pawns could does white have a
claim to being better there it would be
difficult it would be difficult I think
white could well probably hold that
thing yeah no I I don't
what does white have a claim to be
getting better you said no I said if we
vacuumed all that up Oh being better
than he is now is what you know no I
mean could we imagine black winning the
position if we vacuumed up all this yeah
I don't think so I think the Knights
they may not be good at stopping or
catching passed pawns but they are gonna
block hating them right and one thing I
think that'll help understand what
Geoffrey has a grief with is he doesn't
want the past f-pawn if he can do it he
would love to have it past each part
really well yes when we did our thought
experiment right it was like the F pawn
can be blocked with a knight and the
King was we've got an H pawn you
imagined then we're gonna stretch the
King to the two sides as well as the
knight so obviously the other thing the
black has two white us to worry about is
maybe I put my King on b3 not the
easiest thing to achieve but you know I
can dream about it alright so the reason
I like the thought experimenting ways is
the natural plan for black would just be
to go ahead and do
things like h6 and g5 and do those pawn
trades and stuff but it's not enough he
needs to do something more special and
maybe what he can dream about is f6 and
g5 it force him to take this way and
then get this guy running yeah that
looked interesting to me because you
definitely can't allow f6 and then g5
and then takes on h4 right because then
you have two weaknesses on on b2 as well
as h4 and they're too far apart kind of
for the Knights to handle right yeah so
there we have it it's gonna be it's a
very technical problem black is going
white is gonna try to be getting counter
play all the time of course with Knight
of five tricks and 94 tricks and black 2
can think about improving his King and
at some point pushing the pawn down but
there's no rush there's no it was like I
said we're gonna be here for awhile
we're gonna be here for awhile so
that'll be really interesting you know I
just want to say the three games we've
seen Sam play I felt like he got
promising positions in every game and
here he's got he might end up with a
half out of three that's him oh yeah
right this is a pretty rough tournament
so far for Sam to my eyes like this f6
g5 plan looks looks like something white
actually needs to stop pretty pretty
immediately so maybe is can Sam come up
with some idea to stop it or is that
something that isn't quite a threat just
yet
well you know
black can do so many little moves to put
it in preparation if he needs to so I
think long-term though you can't stop
the thing you can dream about some some
counter-attack against the black pawns
I'm sure that's what he's looking at
yeah it's not not an easy business all
right
I think the last game in the egg group
also looks pretty interesting yeah and
you know what let's bring up if we can
the list of 2700 players will talk about
Sam's plight here for a second all right
Mike we'll get that up when we get it up
and let's go to the wane oh here we go
oh that's a little bit a little bit hard
to see but I just wanted to show that it
highlighted there are the three players
that we have playing in the tournament
that are over 2700 Shanklin Jones and
Liam and what I want to say about Sam is
like the guy at a late stage in life
made it into like I think he got up to
like 22 22 in the world after several
good tournaments and you can see playing
in a tournament like this where you're
playing like these guys who are like the
26 80s in the world that is much it's
just like really difficult for him to
maintain the status and it's so easy for
him to just fall down and so really
brutal one thing to we're going to talk
about with Jeffrey is Jeffrey like we
saw in the interview of course his next
hurdle is making 2,700 breaking into
this club and in a lot of ways this
2,700 Club is what this a group is about
thank you how how high can you go up
there and can you just maintain your
status and I know it's funny you know
Sam I I know that when he got to like 22
he was just thinking about going further
up the list and the problem is that's a
great dream but you know just preventing
the fall down the list oh man really
tough I know there's like a ton of
players in that 26:42 2670 range
right and every one of them would love
to make that jump up to where kind of
sand is right now so it's tough to make
that climb but it might be tougher to to
hold off the masses right right and so I
that's kind of what's at stake in the a
group let's look at Gawain Jones this
game he was one of the people in that
2700 list all right and this has been
madness for a long time one thing it's
funny about that both English players is
when I watch them up there they act
anyway maybe they're just putting on a
show for day you know or their opponent
about whether they're prepared or not
but they both of those guys Jones and
how will they kind of look at the board
they hem and haw you know shaking back
and forth and it's like as if they
didn't know what they were gonna do
going into the game and so here this
Archangel thing is tried and there we go
I thought this looked pleasant for white
but it's clearly and always is a total
mess in these positions rookie 197 and
we're introducing the madness here with
90 cent but I just want everyone should
explain in general what the idea is not
only is the night in the way of the
bishop but the night is being dominated
by the pawn on c3 so in general and the
ruie you you want to move this guy
so does 97 is very provocative it allows
white to start thinking about taking
this part and taking this boy white
decided okay I'll take that one just
pure madness now but I guess we would
want to say that white is for choice
something like that I don't know for a
move there could I thought d4 was
hanging for a second but there I guess
obviously there is some idea see Bishop
takes d4 for a move yeah I don't know I
guess this whole this whole line is
pretty
yes theoretical indeed night of seven
something like the goodness you know I
don't know the the line might go on with
like Bishop f2 and maybe another way to
doing is playing route before first
mmm-hmm Wow
yeah but if this that's kind of what is
behind the scenes going on here these
you know this these people who do this
Archangel thing these people yeah though
it's a certain kind of person that wants
to do this because you have to be
willing to take on weird positions right
my sense too is that after a for there's
a loads of different opportunities for
black I thought at least back in the day
that rookie egg was the main move but
obviously sure you could play before and
just total mayhem total mayhem a
ninety-seven very provocative do I know
what's happening not really but it looks
like White's better
oh look at that move Wow kind of just
jumping out look at this one boom my
goodness
boom oh my god is like a lot of games
are taking this turn today with a lot of
conflict in the center and pieces being
taken and lots of tactical ideas
it
so here's our position clearly we've had
a mess it looks to me yeah I don't know
if that this most times it seemed funny
to you it when it says 125 are we
talking to what I'm talking about I
think there there might have been some
some real a summary this hats going on
we could zoom in on the board there I
think we got a view of the clock
actually going on so it's really it's
two minutes to 17 that makes sense to
you you're gonna be in a time scramble
this is horrendous time trouble really
with 15 moves left Wow
and the wane they're actually let's
let's update it mm-hmm maybe we'll just
follow this live for a second it's it's
white sees a lever way to hold on to his
beautiful c6 pawn he's got a minute and
50 seconds to find it he's pushing it
alright
I like the wheat we can see it before he
even gets the relay and the good news
for Gawain is he can think for a little
bit any way to figure out how to address
it seems like why it shouldn't be
holding on to this pawn right well let's
do some variations at your bishop visa
issue c6 first instincts let me ask a
weird question can I do this yeah I was
kind of worried you might ask
let's just see what happened today I
don't know if it works so snip snip and
I was gonna snip yeah this this the back
crank idea is really coming forward and
no still not over juice on five yeah
yeah and I I don't know trying to make
some triangles trying to make the
triangles yeah I don't know it looks
like you're kind of sort of holding on
there like what can I do annoying stuff
like rook air-five
got five Queenie seven Ricky five Queen
f8 I guess kind of being pushed back and
I need a trick obviously Oh is there
rook c8 rook b8 Knight d7 something like
that but you know you could bail out in
that position you could play rook takes
Knight ah well he's got two minutes to
think though so let's see we did have
this should be saying c7 because we saw
a c7 on the board we see c7 and then
going I think played rook d7 instead of
Bishop e6 right so c7 or decent now the
good news for white is it because it's
black smooth not really sure he wants to
take that pawn
yeah maybe he's just stepping out of any
night see for stuff so he can take his
time collecting upon and let's say the
obvious that the problem for white is
how do I effectively use this guy this
rook on f3 that pawn on d4 kind of
actually stifling that rook a little bit
above to come to c3 or even III on the
open files but no entry for that rook or
or daro here what is this supposed to do
I'm sure he's this is where you know
people are gonna make mistakes this rook
B 3 is a thought at least you're doing
something with the rook and yeah let's
zoom in again let's see that timing oh I
can kind of sit there oh yeah 50 seconds
yeah maybe we'll just stay on on this
view cuz I think short the actions gonna
keep going you know one thing I really
admire about these guys is what they can
do that I really have trouble with is
they can let it dip all the way down to
like under five seconds and then play
their move
yeah in my experience when that happens
I'm just I'm counting seconds in my head
and I'm getting like no actual position
I'm just like ten nine eight but so
besides rook b3 there's gotta be some
other tricks and let's just say the
obvious black is at some point very soon
gonna play d3 in which case he's gonna
open his was Bishop he could have done
it last move to seven oh here you see
what I mean clean clean for floor feels
like a little bit he's a like a I'm
bailing out right yeah I think he's
ready to say please let's simplify a
little bit I'm gonna give you my C pawn
just give me some trades so I can
survive it's gotta be a bummer though
because now black can't really be worse
I don't think yeah I definitely would
pick black here let's just do the
obvious so takes takes tanks
and let's say the problem is that this
guy isn't in but maybe I could do it
that if it goes like this and claim that
at least I'm blockading your stuff and
my rook isn't totally useless
yeah it's serving a purpose now the
lateral defense now there were other
things black could have done of course
but oh you know what here it was oh
right there we did see it on the way
maybe maybe equality is as where it's
heading towards well I'm sure go Wayne
is looking for a knockout blow because
well not knockout but just some way to
keep the game alive he's got so many
different moves in play Queen be seven
eight Queen d6 as well
Queen Queen d6 you have to think about
94 but yet Queen d6
yeah and I wanted to mention some of
these players I think kind of have an
uncanny ability where they don't even
look at the clock and then they'll
confidently play their move as as the
seconds run out and that's that's really
one of the most impressive things to me
is keeping that kind of composure and in
situations like these here's a weird
variation chirps thinking about Queen g5
94 this might be insane snip
so if the next year you have an x-ray
Jase ya know you could I guess play here
and then here and then here but in
contrast the last one here black has the
C file also the f7 pawn is following
them just take some c4 and then takes on
f7 maybe hitting the bishop might be a
problem yeah so he's thinking about all
kinds of stuff like that wouldn't be
seven plain b7 I don't know if likes in
a huge rush to take this pawn on c7
because it kind of as soon as that pawn
kind of falls off the board all of
whites play seems pretty pretty forest
straight and trades kind of start
appearing on the C file one funny thing
actually is clever maybe got Queen d7 is
if the natural route b3 let's just
assume it's Queen c7 mhm
snip snip snip snip there's no blockade
on the C 4 square right and there's no
way at least a long term I guess is
stalking this guy rip III played I think
with the 105 seconds on his clock yeah
rugby 3 so we have in season yeah this
was not hard to foresee and I guess he's
gonna have to snip now the good news is
he's gonna gain some time but that's he
filed her - I think Queen d7 was a
really cold-hearted move because now
there's no blockade on c4
what what else can we do besides capture
it he should play this quite quickly I
would think I don't know he's concerned
yeah yeah you got to think it and with
that little time on the clock you got to
take the force to it as where you can
without well he's I'm sure he's thinking
about what to do right here yeah yeah it
looks well I don't know how he might
just simply be fine after King f1 that's
what he does okay good
he's gonna make time control now by the
way you know it really is a thing with
these time controls that you can play on
you can get into dirty time pressure and
then totally live through it it was 30
seconds look at that a couple of moves
he made it's back up to 119 takes some
getting used to I think he's fine
I was I thought it for a second that
black kid accomplished something but
honestly if the King comes up to d3 I
don't know why black should be better
and our rook on b3 is a pretty proud
piece because he at least prevents or
makes it difficult for the black group
to move off the seventh and it seems
like black owes a couple moves before
you can really start trying to do
anything with this pieces Kings a bit
stuck on the back rank and his bishops a
little trapped on a 7 as well how old's
upset so rookie 7 preventing the king
here's White's got several moves you
know night see for them let's go and
take a look at Howl's game this has been
a mess for a long time that game looks
rather insane just saw Capshaw enough
six I think and why don't I just take it
from the point where there was a cool
tactic we're in this actually black is
the one who initiates it here I think
black is mostly okay in this position
but he initiates this madness where he
goes snip snip snip snip snow and maybe
what he missed or miss evaluated was
after Bishop g5 I can do that and go
back and white now has a simple claim
that his King is better and you know the
pawn weaknesses one is important but the
king is a bigger deal right so 93 all
kinds of things gonna happen here but I
think we have to say whites on top yes
some some weak light squares definitely
a thi even even even have five as well
okay three very nice move simple chess
simple chest I like it a lot this is an
interesting decision well yeah that's
not what I would expect to see
I guess night f4 was not a source the
thing and you know the other point is
just I kind of want to trade down
because if I the closer I have the more
I trade the closer I get to the king of
course now though the bishops that they
have a real claim so it's just a
question of how much drama the White
Nights can start and so here he starts
night h4 23 f4 so that's his that's his
lover once that f-pawn to make makes
noise and if Bishop f4 I'm assuming its
rookie 7 this is the grief so check to
the rook this looks very unpleasant very
penny I really this is a nice night well
really nice game from white so far Hans
role let's call that a speculative
sacrifice no in this is where it starts
I think he's going to have the idea of
playing 95 when he does this simply
because the knight doesn't have that
much of a future on g6 so he must have
come up with the idea here Wow now that
one interesting question is like does he
really have no other safe way to play me
I mean maybe he doesn't
so yeah well I don't get this yeah I had
some questions maybe for one for example
I I was thinking about Knight h5 for
white instead of f5 I don't know
age five huh
what's what's the threat I don't know if
there is one which is why maybe it's not
a great move but maybe I'll just play
Rick f3 and then York g3 like I don't
know let's go here okay
yeah just renewing the threat not on the
night but I think you're right it's it's
remarkable this decision is really
remarkable in it I'm gonna just try to
imagine that I'm in white shoes and do I
believe like what do I think about this
position right do I feel like I'm
winning or just compensation I feel I'd
feel pretty confident right it's one of
those ones where you just have you say
okay blacks King is is wide open and um
these two pawns must be worth at least
at least a piece the concern might come
from those C and D pawns right they're
like well in sacrifice the piece and
still be up quite a bit of material okay
yeah and I guess one way intuitively to
just say this for white I think is that
black can do all kinds of stuff here but
I am guaranteed to get both pawns on the
6th and that's what happens
now I would be scared I'd definitely be
scared those bishops are strong Queen b3
now he just if there's all kinds of
moves black could do here
a5 Bishop c5 black says let's bring the
Queen in now east 7 I'm gonna call e7 a
very committal move because now black
knows that it's the light squares that
he needs to blockade absolutely but this
is not the way it goes down so we're
saying if rook f7 we have eh and if rook
e8 we have f7 hmm so what to do
black says check snip and then I'm
assuming Queen takes f6 in fact moves
have been played on the board so like in
our other games hit they're gonna and I
think these are the true times of 33
seconds
yeah well close close let's the Queen f6
snip like you said it was gonna be
giving back the piece and actually like
the other English game we have a pawn on
d4 both English men have a pawn on d4
with a with a bishop the other one has a
dark square bishop snip I don't know
about d4 men I guess
snip I mean I that's a happy pawn rook
e8 Queen d7 Queen afore we should expect
obviously some mistakes are both players
in time pressure this looks I would be
feeling not so comfortable with either
color where is this night going you have
to play King age 2 issues looks like he
made some move oh he did play King age
dude I don't know if there's another
choice that was move 44 lilium and
how all needs a good move c5 played
so white held on to this e seven pond
but it seems blockaded for the moment
and black is is aiming to to push his
pawns push his own pawns I think I think
I take black here black arch isn't your
King worse my King is worse but my pawns
I think are better maybe Ricky six this
posix sure if I can solve this move then
I think I definitely wouldn't be playing
with the black pieces I'll just play
Queen f7
yeah I'm not sure where you're going I'm
gonna play d3 next and then if you let
me I'll play D - okay so yeah I I don't
know exactly what what you do here but
definitely the better King means that we
should have a variety of nice moves here
it's definitely technical your team
might be a little safer but it's not
completely safe and maybe a way to just
talk about it is to say that I need to
find a way then maybe I wanted to think
about as I'm sure that the M is think
about here of activating the night now
rookie six definitely the most natural
move that's that's the thing is this I
don't see how this night ever moves
well okay let's just play a couple
natural moves mm-hmm and let's say I do
Queen d6 I'll play d3 and I'm not sure
about this but let's try this one
okay this looks like some tactics I
guess I like weensie seven and then nine
to five less tactics I just want to you
know can I just take and take on e7 with
a queen I'll take with the queen but
then I have this one okay I'll take with
the rook but both ways
well yeah but then I want to play queen
g6 after you take I mean okay let's see
here there's no black does every threat
though right I guess not I guess you're
you're up up a pond with a better king
with with the better King yeah okay what
do you what do you play with way cuz I
might play wreck f7 and then okay I'll
take you okay
I might not play you know this one seems
to have worked out in White's favor yeah
so I'm sure he's thing about all kinds
of things right that's just the most
natural where I think with especially
with rook f6 I'm just trying to get a
that f5 square for the night okay so
beautiful game and let's take a look at
poor sim we're just going to be checking
in with poor Sam every once in a while
here you get the updates and basically
the massage has continued right black
let's just let's just take a look he
chose h6 by the way there's it seems
pretty non-committal as long as you can
still do the f6 plan you can still play
age 5 mostly you want to make sure
there's no tricks within the white
knights you know doing stuff to you over
there I think I think in particular he
was trying to take away Knight g5 tricks
with page six
and you know the bummer for white is he
got he's got so many things to worry
about amongst others now if you stay
away from 93 the king why so you know go
king c5 and King before why not yeah so
92 on the board the Knights have seemed
to move back a rank from from the
previous homes it's a difficult life for
the poor knights yeah so right we'll
check in with that I think you know we
can see a long massage happening
rookie one you can feel - right the
black black can kind of wait and go back
and forth and on every move Sam is the
one who has way more stress in the
situation maybe we could check in with a
gang Ghoulies game over in the B group
looks like he's making making some
progress in his game actually I'm in D
same as I it's tough to tell it's a lot
of weaknesses for black but that deep on
seems to have just been captured so
let's go to where we were we had King F
495 is where we left him and I was
saying that it's beautiful for white but
he still has to figure out how to press
g5 home there's no rush so Bishop d4
Knight goes back this is c5 g6 ok
so it's kind of like a critical question
for black of how how and when do I want
to do this stuff yeah and this is going
to be let's call it a more active
attempt at counter play because you are
allowing now this rook to come over but
you're saying check to the misérable
King and notice that he keeps the pawns
on black squares and the advantage is
there that the bishop won't get free
reign on the dark squares a lot of times
people do I notice this thing with some
of my students their instinct is to put
it on the opposite color of the bishop
but here the attempt by Sam is to keep
it on the same
so I think that's the principle that a
lot of people learn is especially in
like a single Bishop versus single
Bishop endgame you want it on the other
color but with so many pieces on the
board bishops actually stronger when you
put the pawns on the opposite color
because then the bishop can kind of
sneak through it and work in
coordination who has more squares yeah
so sam says know what I'm gonna be
active myself and that's nice oh and now
it's now we were in supreme violence
yeah and they just made move 40 so they
were struggling through hectic time
pressure here I don't know what's going
on white does fix get to fix the pawns
in dark squares that's nice
rook do you one so huge mess the
assumption is that white is still better
but that Knight has become a real
octopus well maybe but I'm just looking
at rooks e6 after blacks next move and I
don't see I don't see a way for black to
total Don yeah well he's gonna get
counter play don't write like let's say
I don't know let's say he's obviously
gonna think about it let's say this one
you see six
let's say that one
I will
not give a check what will I do should I
thought chicken I'll get her attention I
thought that was near intention yeah
that was my that's my first plan I guess
but here I'm fortunate I have a to two
reasonable moves King d5 and king D
three
yeah what if I'd take on f6 yeah King
itch oh this is this is more crazy than
I wanted so yeah I think it's it's
become more complicated than then
ganguly wanted it Knight f4 is on the
board let's um let's look for a second
at how this madness happened so 95
happens
Bishop d4 and maybe white was a little
complacent in believing us I think I
think I actually believed with him that
he could kind of just sit but Sam found
a way to get counter play let's say he
already and it's aw I'm gonna say he
foresaw rook h1 because that's the
natural move force now white could have
also played g5 but then that you know
the king has got his own grief after g5
so rook h1 check
now white had the option of going Bishop
d4 as well
I push this is luckier boom when you do
this in time pressure you're gonna have
no idea but you just have no idea
exactly what's happening
so metaphor was the way instead of four
takes d4 Knight f4 wait to move here
I want to I want to checkmate this black
King in the middle of the board somehow
but thank you for strengthening is a
little funny
so let's I'm not sure wait wait well
what is the idea of nighttime or let's
try to understand is he trying to do
like a rook h8 h3 thing
so maybe a problem with with Rick takes
d4 it was Ricky to check and then
bringing the rook into e6 rather than
rather than c6 okay and then you don't
really get this this annoying stuff with
95 well you play 95 but I get to take
your Eirik off of the d4 square 9 f4
so he's thinking about it this is gonna
be this is gonna be an element we're
getting we're gonna need some better
ball games so I think the intention is
to say this part isn't going anywhere
and this is coming this way
and the part is in fact in the way of
the bishop so we entered a little
pressure let's just say we do this this
check right I wanted to yeah I wanted to
check them and try to find some way to
narrow this the good news for black is
if he doesn't want to take the part
maybe just does that then I might play
Seabrooke h2 and get there first
well he's he's he's going to though yeah
play rook III can you um it's a lot of
squares to try to keep under you could
also play rook h1 and SEM and I just
want to add and I'm 94 you could also
think about just saying you have to
leave now please we can make the guy
leave so I have another another weird
idea what if I played d5 instead of
Bishop c1 or rook e1 because I really
kind of agree that this pawn is is in my
own way
well let me ask you something let's say
you're in this building do you think
you're better is wider yeah you do I do
because I think III just feel like I
should be ahead at this pawn on f6 is
going is going to fall and it's just a
matter of finding the right way to do it
without losing horribly and getting
checkmated but it feels like feels like
there should be something here the black
King on e4 is it doesn't seem right
nothing seems right to me to me I would
feel right for black is you know before
I felt like just 10 moves ago we were in
a situation it looked like we'd be
suffering for hours and at least here we
have chances of who knows what's going
to happen okay
I like this d5 move though what happens
I have no idea Black has a lot of
different options he can play one of the
rooks let's just count them one of the
rooks tha aids the h-file he can take
maybe he can take that way and maybe
he's got some other move so at least
four moves that he can do so again so a
lot of the moves I wanted to play rook
c4 check okay
and then you have to make an efficiency
one
yeah Bishop c1 wasn't my idea if King
III okay let's just try this thing okay
and here I was thinking I was thinking
either you still do your roof
rooks c4 but I was also considering rook
e1 check and then I guess King d3 gains
a tempo on me I'll play rook to a square
that square is c6
and I wanted to play I I don't think I
have quite enough time but some
combination of Bishop b4 and and saying
that I've caught you in fact maybe maybe
I'll play I don't know I'll stick with
York c6 right now but wreck h8 is I'll
say is I don't know who's getting caught
catching d5 is certainly a move though
yeah yeah really there should be some
way to catch catch the King I really
really think so
I thought night at 4 was like I mean I
guess that's the last yeah it was the
last seconds of time pressure I'm not
sure that was it didn't feel right to me
to move I didn't want to move in the
night yeah your thing was though that
rook if rook d4 in rookie two did that
was the problem
yeah that was my night claim and again
just so I understand king d5 it's a
rookie six
okay this is it's a sudden think about
for sure so let's go some other games
this is what we're gonna come back to
this position with Knight f4 yeah
Ganguly is rightfully you know saying
I've reached me forty we're gonna mellow
out a little pip
and let's look at this we haven't looked
at any games of get woozy on yet and I
don't know why I clicked on that look at
how it's saying that is what am i doing
what do you see here camera man there's
no normal games anymore well I first
glance I like white but you need more
than a first glance I think to
understand okay let's see the problem
for white is that let's go back one move
so this is the last move right and
obviously this b6 is hanging and the
pawns can potentially rule but if I get
f5 I assume f5 is coming soon this night
at least will be misplaced and I'm
hoping for counter play on the dark
squares right and right away in fact
some things have happened so quick I see
b6 has a pricing thing so clean decent
we need b6 wait so 94 rook e1 mm-hmm
Queen between b6
oh boy alright so obviously we got a
problem with the rook I don't really
want to play passively with rote visa
Wow
and we need to do something right away
because the improving move Knight f3 is
really a big deal for wine maybe rook c8
is is a start yeah yeah something active
like rook c8 and white alright so we've
got a weird position here like the
bishops just on pre ins the King is a
little a little Airy perhaps
well yeah it's acquaintance who's King
is area though this this guy's known at
some point it like I want to take this
part at some point but then there's like
this problem Plus that problem no yeah
the the white king so rook d7 was played
I wasn't thrilled about it because it
looks kind of passive but it does
control this rank which the black king
is hanging out on Oh
there's actually a pretty critical
update Shanklin has actually drawn his
game against general oh he held it so
yeah in the end the Knights got the job
done see the two kings in the century
they're declaring the draw it looks like
the Knights fountains actually some
active squares it's a long way from when
we last saw them on d2 at night see to
re-tune so let's just see how that
finished alright we saw something like
this mm-hmm
a one check
95 the nights are getting active right
the key to drawing this thing is to get
them somehow active rook f1 Knight f4 oh
and then they decided to draw I wonder
about that
I don't know Geoffrey I don't know buddy
he could have played on well at a
minimum let's just say I do this move Oh
Knight f4 Knight c3 late c3
that aforethought - it's you know
there's no threat on the part really
hasn't yeah oh that's gotta be a
disappointment for Jeffrey oh man okay
so Sam is one and at one point out of
three I thought he was beautiful games
in all three let's check out Gawain sure
we have this position and there's a
dirty trick here where we're preventing
the King from coming in because if King
d5 don't often see it discovery with a
king
so the question really is all about Ken
white hold the blockade on d3 or not if
he can't which is looking hard to do
then he's in trouble
wherein he does that night even go do
you actually want to get Sam or Jeffery
in the studio to kind of talk about that
game before we have to close out our
show here
I thought only winners got to be down
here I think it'll be a really technical
analysis let's let's keep looking all
right let's keep looking at this cuz
this is pretty exciting as well as a lot
of the other games going on so there's
this well so let's just say let's leave
this but say that white needs a good
move here yeah because this is kind of
hard I did want to mention it looks like
the game with David Howell has actually
progressed we thought we were saying we
called some moves here and in this
position my first instinct was rook f6
probably that there might be other ideas
to Buttrick f6 looks real hard to meet
maybe just us do a basic tactics check
here well we got this guy and we're
holding our business so that's looking
good with Liam
and we haven't looked at Friedman's game
this has been a wild affair for a long
time it was a double Brook ending and a
basic question is is it's does white
have a chance well with the extra pawn
maybe it always seems to be Manson
maybe he does one nice thing for him on
this movie five which you just did is on
age five it's really important that
that's a check because I don't like if I
go in back to g3 the king would come to
f5 so then I'm King here now white needs
a good move and King g3 is a little bit
sad mm-hmm
so maybe the intention is to go for I
think what the King sidelines enough I
was a decent trying it's still oh we've
still got work to do but this is yeah
this is an interesting attempt where
maybe even after f4 what could claim
that black is in sook swamp yeah right
for example rook h1 King f6 the King h7
is better square than age six but if you
go to H if you go to another square then
you're giving me you can't give me that
one no I'm sorry I meant so King h6 and
then when you said black is maybe Zuko's
Wong's maybe a black plays King gauge oh
yeah yeah fair enough
still that's going to be as
similar kind of is Richie five but okay
King age six it's not the most brilliant
idea I've ever had but
me so I can get the same position but if
I just let's see if I just wait a move
sure
oh wait to say I don't have to be that
complicated right I can play King g5
yeah force you out okay so then we're
gonna go back in now f5 or king of six
as well yeah that looks like the end so
let me just show what this position
looked like a while back
even though guys it's been going on a
long time we've had this kind of dynamic
from the beginning of this end game
where maybe black should be holding but
it's rough absolutely black gets the
active rooks but the pawn weakness over
there is gonna make it difficult yeah
this is a tough end gaming to hold and
so the massage is just beginning here
and E 5 this movie 5 I admire over here
blacks thinking about it now the person
we got to check in with oh wait before
we check in yeah you get some props here
Ganguly played your move man
all right deflate your move smashing it
open really smashing rook takes d5
happened there takes d5 alright your
intention was originally rook e1 was my
intention you want and I thought maybe
King d3 here and I wasn't sure if rooks
e1 and rook c6 or option C which I
haven't found let's say Brooke c6 is the
scariest looking
yeah just for now well my idea was a
little hope chest with Oryx T 1 I was
like Bishop b4 Rick CD 1 and then the I
guess know one thing that's really nice
about the bishop before is I can't do
this yeah so so my concern was Rick h8
in which position so king d3 Rick c6
HHA fair enough
yeah like I said I I wasn't my sense is
like the unless you really made me
there's gonna be counter play even if
you win the pawn 100% right so now in
King be three there might be like you
said there might be some other moves I
think you also mentioned rook h2 ah yeah
and that like makes it difficult for me
to move a rip-off of the default cause
of rook e1 stuff yeah that is this looks
like the safest option may be to just
try to keep all of all the black stuff
out of your face and you know he's
really hard to calculate let's say rook
c8 yeah maybe maybe just Bishop b2
closing in closing is losing it yeah
maybe someday I'm gonna take one of your
pieces I don't know which one let's look
at our fair friend yeah it was the
future genius of the world
Brandon Jacobson he's been suffering for
a while and you know it's funny it's
this will be a I think an interesting
test for him because the kid is
obviously very good at tactics obviously
very good at playing quickly and
openings but now we're gonna see how
well he suffers yeah welcome welcome to
suffering yeah he has yeah it's you know
I would just say this is a clear
advantage for white it's not unless he's
got something amazing now I don't see
anything more special than that it must
be an advantage maybe he can try and get
his rook if he gets his route to e2 then
he has something to say right that age
to pawn is a little bit backward it's a
little bit under defended but I don't
see how that ever that ever happens for
black one thing I'm sure White's
considering now is f5
okay I'll play King what's fine King f7
probably b3 b3 ins yeah I'll take your
pawn I'll take your pawn f4 and I'm
losing okay anyways I don't want to take
white doesn't have to play F yeah look I
think when you look at what he's done
with the rook going to h8 that he's it's
my dreaming of something like that might
be his intention yeah it looks it looks
like a good attempt I mean I'm sure
there's other moves too he can just
calmly play King d3 I don't want to
allow the King F even their king the
header either well I don't know why I
Blake gig b3 but the there's all kinds
of things like like that to rook f8 I'm
cooling the upon so he's got a wide
choice and this tournament of course
would be a wide open if Brandon loses
it's gonna be what it's really wide open
anyway Wiz it 10 round tournament we got
a long way to go so maybe there's some
there's always some tactics I don't
think Rick f8 is is too viable right
there's discoveries usually you know
something like king d7 and then and then
rookie 3 or something yeah or maybe I
guess FF 5 rather it's it's tough
actually cuz King d7 maybe there's a
there is no king d5 I guess I don't know
what I'm saying I'm trying to like
attack the bishop with my case yeah the
discovery doesn't work and in the rook
f8 idea he can move the King first if
he's worried about yeah some kind of
stuff let's look at the count the counts
you know had a rough first round with
the room felt and honestly I felt like
his opponent was again first round he
lost a Brandon and Brandon was very well
prepped
and this round it's turned into a French
structure where it looks difficult it
looks real difficult for black not
totally lost or anything but difficult
with the rook and Knight always
threatening to create play and black
white just played rook c1 so this is
another loss for clearly worse one of
them take your pick you think your pick
white still has to prove you know some
stuff
well black can create a little play
would might be five and rook a seven so
white needs to yeah he has to be very
exact actually 95 so I'm assuming ninety
seven that's the idea in this position
well actually he was already there so so
right let's go back a touch yeah maybe
five King III he's just been pushing him
around yeah
I'm assuming thou Knight b5 will come
back and there is there's real problem
technical problems for y I very much
believe in its position but we need to
get into the f7 squared
yeah it's a it's a difficult and if we
don't want to leave b3 behind if we go
this one he's coming this one so so
tougher wait to make progress but donít
lien on paper a very nice position for
white but stable advantage maybe but
what well I don't know it you know it's
like he needs to do something right now
because route c7 and rook a 7-hour
question mark okay so let's take a look
at maybe a quick look overall at the
remaining games see what we kind of
expect to happen
sure let's look at our friend GU boos
Ian we had this position and they're
still thinking on rook d7
incredibly complicated and I will say I
have no idea I have no idea what's gonna
happen in that game yes a lot still up
in the air definitely some part of me
believes in black and part of me
believes in white I really don't know
marathon games and I think we can safely
say that you know both players will
probably make mistakes in the next
couple of those be right it's so hectic
these are actually the two victims of
Ganguly so I'm sure they're they're
hoping to make their comeback here yeah
so yeah let's look at your game alright
it's called your game gank Ali's game
I'll take it
there are worse games to have and well a
lot of progress has been made here let's
see
so d5 snip check that was the other move
you mentioned Bishop c1 kingi to snip
snip rookie for
it's a lot less complicated than some of
those other lines it's so pretty
complicated though right I mean well
yeah but at least one record a lot of
the the direct threats against that the
black King I think they're kind of
clarified
I don't think maybe I'm missing some
stuff but I don't think the lack has any
problems anymore like let's say I play
okay so maybe this is the intention so
clearly he's making a claim that about
the pen because otherwise we can say
that the black King is a hero yeah
if rook c8 can we are we getting away
with that yeah that was my question as
well I think concerns you you are you
have concerns though King King g2
something like rook c5
okay I'll play Bishop h6
93 is gonna Knight c3 it's gonna happen
you know yeah okay there's like route
gauge to or if d2 I'm sorry
and then after King e1 maybe maybe I can
start generating some threats like oh
I'm sorry I was saying Bishop h6 first
and then you were saying Knight c3 so
let's see so if I play Bishop h6 here to
it and before we get off in the wind
this is our position
yeah black has to if he I think White's
dream is to say something like well the
pin is so annoying that you will
eventually have to break it by something
like rook d7 b5 Knight b6 and at that
point I'm gonna really start saying my
minor piece is awesome mm-hmm
and I'm gonna try to avoid all the dirty
tricks so if you don't play rook c8
you're gonna have to do I guess the 7
thing right so Rick t7 here but then it
has a few turns he's got a lot of
dealings and he could even play a 4 and
it concerns me so that's why at least
that's the first thing to come to my
mind snip
yeah check kingi it looks like a stable
pawn
let's say check
takes I guess I'll take
and the rook d6
now I'm not sure about this but
for
yeah this looks like a problem
I was thinking in general if I have the
activity I should be able to hold it but
it's I was thinking maybe Rick a foreign
sitter of t6 that might have been a
slight misstep
and Yelp licking g3
my idea now is I just want to play
something like rook c4 and I think that
King and pawn endgame should be winning
and I guess I have to play King h3 or H
2 H 2
yeah I'll cook c6 I don't know
they can age three
and I guess King g5 well I mean I can do
this if nothing else we do we can repeat
the dance right yeah fair enough so some
some complications
I guess though this is Sam's thinking
about it now and that's gonna be his big
question about you know do our flavour
oxy eight or do I try to just keep the
night stable mm-hmm on d5 and let's just
look at it for a second while we
consider his plight so this is our
position the argument for keeping it
stable is to say well white can't
actually do anything no well that's what
he's thinking about right as you either
go for the rook c8 style suffering or
you sit so actually flex it so I was
thinking Rick d2 might be might be a
problem for black
maybe and then I you know there's all
kinds of problems that is Lee and I
there's different ways of sitting - I
can play a five mm-hmm I can play B five
directly here's an idea if you've placed
something like a five or B five
can i play Bishop takes g5 no what are
you doing though I'm playing you have
six on the knife seven and then take
might imagine I just put my rook on d7
after you play off six and I take it
okay
and then I I win the g5 fun I think know
as we checks and all kinds of counter
play but here look you can do you can do
a similar idea yeah where you can say
look up try to put the bishop somewhere
on B to move the rook somewhere and then
tickle but right the the the the problem
for Sam is he has to if he if he doesn't
go for rook c8 and he's decided to sit
he needs to try to imagine he's white
and think about all the nasty things
that white can try to do to him right
right not not a pleasant idea but okay
let's make some predictions I guess I'm
gonna say that's about a draw I don't
know
grigory I just yeah and so we're looking
at the standing over so we see Jeffrey
Zhong and Sam have drawn their game what
are we expecting from David Hal against
Lee M Leigh we that position has
progressed I still think White's much
better I'd be surprised if he doesn't
win that one so possibly uh Liam's first
win then against right and I would shake
up the pairings of the standings a
little bit and then there is our Darius
wits against Gawain Jones that's
probably gonna be a draw it's like a
draw
so maybe peaceful results for a couple
of the games in Group A and maybe Liam
Leake taking his his first win over in
Group B all the games are kind of still
up in the air
so yeah Ganguly likely going to maintain
his lead no matter what his result is
maybe a draw maybe there's something to
play for
he is actually paid against sam-7 so and
then Daniel Friedman against a Gregorio
Perrine what did I say White's gonna win
that one but it could go either way so
maybe a UH grigory's first win putting
men at +1 maybe he'll be the one to try
to chase down a Ganguly here in goo
Goo's e'en against Kovalenko yeah let's
pretend that we made some progress he's
gotten at least a night back so maybe
looking good for for Igor but definitely
a lot of chess to be played and finally
over in the C group Brandon Jacobson is
suffering a bit down upon in an end game
but he might be able to hold that to
maintain his lead Alshon has drawn his
game against Coco bein so putting him at
three draws for the tournament on a
level score and then the final game
Gordievsky against Christian is actually
looking looking a little a little testy
for black but Heath can if you can
survive the next few moves
probably a probably a draw so the
leaders kind of maintaining their
positions thus far possibly with the
exception of Brandon Jacobson we do have
some exciting upcoming broadcasts though
after the summer chess classic which
will be here for a while but up next is
the grand chest tour in Croatia from
June 26th to July 8th we will have live
coverage with some of the world's top
GM's the grand chest or regulars will be
playing in that and coming up directly
after that is the u.s. Junior
Championship the girls Junior
Championship and for the first time in
st. Louis the u.s. Senior Championship
and so it'll be a whole a month-long
period here where we're having broadcast
nearly every day should be a lot of fun
of course I'm Caleb Denby it's
Grandmaster Jessie cry you can join us
here pretty much every day except for
the rest day on Sunday starting at 3:30
p.m. for more coverage of the summer
chess classic thank you all for joining
us today thank you
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
[Music]
you
you
you